[Music]
hello
and welcome to the authority gap i'm
marianne sicard
when mary mcaleese was president of
ireland she led an official visit to the
vatican to meet
pope john paul ii she was in the
audience room at the head of her
delegation
about to be introduced to him when he
reached straight past her
held out his hand to her husband instead
and asked him
would you not prefer to be president of
ireland rather than married to the
president of ireland
her husband knew better than to take the
pope's hand and she told me in an
interview for the authority gap
i reached and took the hand which was
hovering in midair and said let me
introduce myself
i am the president of ireland mary
mcaleese elected by the people of
ireland
whether you like it or whether you don't
however much we say we believe in
equality these days
we're still in practice more reluctant
to accord authority to women
than to men even when they're leaders or
experts
every woman has a tale to tell about
being
underestimated talked over ignored
patronized interrupted and generally not
taken as seriously as a man
and when i say woman of course i mean
anyone who presents as a woman
great strides have been made and many
men are good and respectful listeners
but however liberal we think we are
we're nowhere near there
there's still what i call an authority
gap between women and men
and the authority gap is the mother of
all gender gaps
because if women aren't taken as
seriously as men they're going to be
paid less
promoted less and held back in their
careers
they're going to feel less confident and
less entitled to success
if we don't do anything about it the gap
between women and men
will never disappear now when i put
together some slides to give another
lecture on this
i knew i had to start by defining my
terms so i took a screenshot of the
oxford dictionary online's definition of
authority
first to come up on my google search and
guess what
every sentence it offered as examples
began with the same pronoun
there was he has the natural authority
of one who is used to being obeyed
he hit the ball with authority and he
was an authority on the stock market
i couldn't have found a neater
illustration of the way we instinctively
associate men
more than women with authority but
didn't margaret thatcher have the
natural authority of one who is used to
being obeyed
doesn't serena williams hit a ball with
authority
isn't helen morrissey an authority on
the stock market
the same happened when i searched in
google images for something to
illustrate a slide on
expertise in the first 20 pictures
there wasn't a single woman bart simpson
appeared
before we reached the first female in a
group with men
and finally there was a decent sized
photo of a woman but
oh it turned out she was having
something explained to her by a male
expert
i'll give you another example of the
authority gap from one of the many
fascinating women i interviewed for the
book
louise richardson is the first woman to
run the university of oxford which is by
some measures
the best university in the world but she
still finds her authority is challenged
she told me a great story she said i
presided at congregation and i sit on a
throne
chairing a meeting with 350 people and
there are a couple of people there who
had a role in it
it was their first time and i've done it
a dozen times
when i was in mid-speech in front of 350
people this guy said
you've got it wrong you should be
reading this pointing to another part of
my script
in front of everybody i said thank you
but actually i've got it right
and i proceeded i said to him the next
day
i'd just like you to give a little
thought to one question
would you have done that yesterday if i
were a male vice chancellor
would you have interrupted a male vc
speaking publicly to a room full of
people in a very formal setting
to correct what they were saying
especially when this was your first time
at the gathering
and as it turned out you were wrong i
said i did that mental experiment myself
last night i'd just like to ask you to
do that mental experiment
so this is the mental experiment i'd
like us all to do every day
we might not notice that we're taking
women less seriously than men
we might not notice that we interrupt
them more challenge their expertise more
and
listen to them less but many of us do
it makes women fume it dents their
confidence and it holds them back
so it's high time we changed our
behavior
and it's not just men who do it but
however progressive and intelligent
or indeed female we think we are
scientific studies show that we all
women as well as men have unconscious
biases
even against our own gender we may not
be aware of them they're called
unconscious for a reason
but they do spill out into our behavior
and unless we notice
and correct for them we'll continue to
assume that a man knows what he's
talking about until he proves otherwise
while for a woman it's all too often the
other way around
the authority gap will remain as wide as
ever
to see this more clearly it helps to
flip things round
so if you're a man try this
imagine living in a world in which
you're routinely patronized by women
imagine having your views ignored or
your expertise frequently challenged by
them
imagine trying to speak up in a meeting
only to be talked over by female
colleagues
imagine women subordinates resisting you
as a boss merely because of your gender
and imagine women superiors promoting
other women
even if they're less talented than you
imagine people almost always addressing
the woman you're with before you
imagine writing a book and finding that
half the population is reluctant to read
it
because it's written by a man imagine
being trolled by women on social media
threatening violence against you
merely for expressing an opinion not
great is it
see the trouble is that privilege is
often invisible
most men simply don't notice it until
it's flipped round like this and why
would they
i struggle to notice my white privilege
yet in everyday life
it's as if men are swimming with the
current in a river and women are
swimming against it
so the men see the banks racing past
them and congratulate themselves for
swimming so powerfully
and they look at the women struggling to
make headway against the current and
think
why can't they swim as fast as me
they're obviously not as good
so this means there is a deep asymmetry
when i talk to men about this subject
a lot of them express skepticism they
tell me the problem's been solved
my thesis is out of date if anything
women are being privileged and they're
suffering
and this is because they can't see the
continuing bias and we
can they don't experience the myriad
little insults to their self-esteem
and competence that women have to put up
with daily or weekly
so not only is their reaction as
wrong-headed as a white person
telling a person of color that racism
doesn't exist
it also proves the exact point of this
book that women's authority is
questioned and challenged
even when they know more than the person
they're talking to
because as you'll see there's a huge
amount of evidence for the continued
existence of the authority gap
and it's resistant to being mansplained
away
now if a woman thinks that she's being
taken less seriously than man
it's hard for her to prove that she's
the victim of discrimination
he just might be better than her and
women are often accused of citing sexism
to disguise their inadequacy
but there's one very persuasive way of
testing this hypothesis
that women are unjustifiably respected
less
and thought to be less competent and
expert than men
talk to people who've lived as both
because they're exactly the same person
with the same intelligence ability
experience and personality
and the only thing that's changed is
their gender they are uniquely able to
identify
the effect of gender in their lives it's
a way of correcting for all the other
variables
and isolating the one that matters now
i'm going to tell you the story of two
science professors at stanford
who happened to transition in opposite
directions at the same time
ben barris a neuroscientist was
astonished by the difference it made to
his life when he started living as a man
i've had the thought a million times he
wrote i am taken more seriously
at one seminar a faculty member who
didn't know his history was heard to say
oh ben barris gave a great seminar today
but then his work's much better than his
sisters
they were of course the same person
darius concluded
by far the main difference that i've
noticed is that people who don't know
i'm
treat me with much more respect i can
even complete a whole sentence without
being interrupted by a man
meanwhile joan roughgarden an
evolutionary biologist
found exactly the opposite when she
started living as a woman
she said you get interrupted you need to
find a male to support what you said
and not get offended if a male says the
same thing and claims credit for it
because at least you got the message out
this is what you have to navigate at
first i was amused she said
after describing how she was much more
frequently interrupted
ignored and condescended to by men
particularly those who hadn't known her
before
i thought if women are discriminated
against then i'm darn well going to be
discriminated against
the same way well the thrill of that's
worn off
i can tell you her conclusion men are
assumed to be competent until proven
otherwise
whereas a woman is assumed to be
incompetent until she proves otherwise
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you